the broadcast is now starting all
attendees are in listen only mode good
morning everybody thank you for taking
this uh Tuesday Morning of January 5th
out to attend this uh presentation my
name is Michael Volos from orderflows
dcom and today I'm going be talking
about finding winning trades in the
order flow you know my goal for you
today is um it's basically to show you
how to leverage the information that's
generated by the market so you're always
trading in the same direction of the
market you know that a simple Concept in
trading but you know people are always
trying to fight the way the market is
going right Market keeps going up people
want to short it Market keeps dropping
people want to keep buying it you know I
was talking to somebody last night they
said oh you know yesterday if you
remember in the S&P we kept dropping
right kept falling falling falling and
the guy like you know I tried to buy a
lost I tried to buy a lost I tried to
buy a lost you know why try to fight the
way the market is going why not go in
the direction of the market and I'm
going to show you how you can use
orderflow to be on the right side of the
market you know on a day like yesterday
where the market just keeps dropping
it's you know it's easy in hind scien to
look back and say yeah you know it was
big down day you should have just been
short but you know most days is is not
as dramatic as as what we saw yesterday
on January 4th now what makes order flow
different than say technical analysis is
you know order flow is not the latest
greatest Fad in trading a lot of people
like to say oh you know order flow is is
the new fad you know that everyone's
trying to get involved and you know
orderflow has been around for you know
well over 100 years if you've ever read
the book reminiscence of a stock
operator right which is one of the the
books that many many great Traders have
said over time is is probably been the
most influential in their career the guy
was a tape reader and that takes place
in the 1920s okay so tape reading and
Order flow is the same thing and it's
what we look at now and consider order
flow is um what they used to call tap in
the past now this training is for
serious traders that want to understand
what is actually happening in the market
again it's not what I'll be talking
about today is is not for people that
are just you know looking to jump from
shiny object to shiny object oh here's a
new indicator I'm going to get it try it
for a couple days oh I lost on three
trades in a row it must be wrong you
know and just move on to something else
order flow is about understanding what's
happening in the market and in this
training you're going to discover an
easy way to see who is in control of the
market right once you know who's in
control of the market right now then you
understand the direction of the market
and when you understand who's in control
of the market you're going to be trading
in sync with the market right you're
going to be going with the direction of
the market rather than trying to keep
fight fighting the
market I want to also talk about why the
market stops and reverses you know when
a market reaches a certain level and
then starts a reversal that makes some
of the best trades that you can have why
because you know imagine you know we
rally up to a high and then we start to
reverse we got the whole entire move of
the day to potentially capture and more
if it keeps continuing and by the end of
this presentation you should come away
with ways to use orderflow to find
winning
trades now my promise is if you stick
around to the end this is going to be no
BS webinar I'm not going to try and
sugarcoat things I'm going to show you
examples just from yesterday because I
want you to understand you know these
what I'm talking about happens every day
in pretty much every single market now
you know some days some markets are
quieter than others but in general what
I'll be showing you today happens every
day in pretty much all markets and if
you stay until the end I'm going to show
you how to get a copy of my book trading
orderflow it's 150 Pages you're not
going to get the actual hard copy you're
going to get uh I'll show you how to get
the link to download um the PDF so you
can download it to your PC or your
smartphone you can print it up if you
like now what makes orderful analysis
such a powerful tool for Traders is
three things
number one order flow gets you as close
as possible to what's happening in the
market right you know as a Trader you
want to be you know on the side of the
market and what's happening right now in
the market and Order flow analysis
allows you to get as close to the market
as possible you know in the old days
right people used to pay hundreds of
thousands of dollars for a membership
for an exchange or they you know they
could lease a seat for thousands of
dollars because they wanted to be there
in the middle of the order flow they
wanted to see what was is happening they
want to take part in
it orderful analysis gives you that
Advantage now that people were paying
thousands of dollars a month for in the
past second reason order flow allows you
to gauge the tendency of Market will
continue in a direction right the new
trading activity the volume is what
keeps the market moving in a direction
you know we've all got into a position
right we've all bought the market the
market immediately sells off why is
because the order flow the the the new
activity that comes in immediately after
you get into a position right may be
contrary to what you thought the market
was going to do so imagine you know you
get long but then all of a sudden the
order flow is
bearish well you're not going to make
any money you're going to get stopped
out but if you can read what that it's
changed in the order flow that's gone
from bullish you know what you thought
was a bullish situation to all of a
sudden bearish you could get out earlier
rather than taking a full stop loss it's
going to allow you to control your
risk now number three
you know you're going to have better
more complete information than pretty
much everybody else I I say 99% but you
know really the amount of people that
use orderflow is so
small that you know it's going to give
you an advantage over everybody else
most people are only looking at the open
high low close and maybe volume right
but most Traders aren't paying attention
to the
orderflow you know sort of the you know
sort of brings up to the the next issue
that that Traders face is not all
Traders are equal right so even though I
say 99% Traders only look at at Open
high low close within that 1% you got
some very big Traders you know big hedge
funds um big portfolio managers that are
starting to look at the data provided by
the order flow so even though it's 99%
you know within that 1% you have some
very massive big funds behind it that
are using orderflow now so again if
you're not using order flow you're going
to get be left in the dust now for those
of you that are not familiar with me my
name is Michael BOS right and I've have
over 25 years professional trading
experience not just trading experience
from my own account no I worked on the
CME floor I started on the CME floor
with Dean Witter Reynolds okay I spent a
few years there and eventually I left to
go work on their upstairs trading desk
the off the floor trading desk when
electronic trading was just starting up
you know CME had Globex uh cbot had
project a NYX had um access NYX comx
they called it access was their system
to their Market the electronic um when
when the markets were starting to move
electronic you know I realized that's
where I wanted to be after I left Dean
Witter Reynolds I joined EDF man the big
English Trading Company on their Global
macro Futures Trading desk in Chicago
and again you know just trading Futures
I've been trading Futures my entire
career after man I joined Commerce Bank
as a licensed urex Trader right you have
in urex in those days to be able to
trade on urex you have to have a license
from the exchange right and it's a big
test you know and in the past I don't
know if they still do some business
schools in Europe required that as a as
as a uh prerequisite to be appli you
know to join their business program you
have to pass that that your ex Traders
test it's it's a pain in the ass test
but you know you have to do it it's much
more difficult than the series 3 believe
me after Commerce Bank I left and I
joined Cargill right the big us
commodity Trading Company I was the head
of the Futures Trading
desk we traded everything you could
imagine um you know that was tradable
there you know whether it's uh futures
or or cash products we traded
everything after cargo I joined JP
Morgan vice president of Futures Trading
all right and again this is the all
these jobs are on the trading desk Trad
right and it's trading at very high
level but after spending 8 years at JP
Morgan you know I just turned like 41
42 gotten married had our first kid and
I realized you know what I don't want to
be wor a slave to a bank in the sense
that you know I love trading but you
know I want to do it on my own I left JP
Morgan I started up order
flows and I was just trading for myself
okay and you know that's the beauty of
being good at trading is you you're able
to do it from anywhere in the world and
you could do it you know you could set
your own hours if you want to work you
don't want to work that's what trading
gives you it gives you freedom and when
I created order flows you know I started
by writing my book right the book that
you get for free but I I
realized you know as I was trading that
software can do more than just um you
know put a a footprint chart you know an
orderflow chart there for me so in 2015
I released the orderflows trader
software now it runs on ninja Trader 8
we just did a recent upgrade to ninja
Trader sorry to orderflows Trader
3.0 and it's a footprint chart an
orderflow footprint chart with
pre-programmed indicators in it to
highlight certain things in the
orderflow to you and the reason why I
talk about this software is because I
want you to understand that the charts
that you're going to see here in this
presentation are generated from that
software and
you if you're using there's a lot of
software out there right orderflow
footprint charts that just put up a
footprint for you right but unless you
know what you're going to look for in
the order
flow it it's pretty useless honestly you
know because you'll just be chasing
windmills right you're going to be donot
chasing after windmills but when you
understand what to look for and that's
why I'm doing this presentation is to
show you things that you can look for if
you're just using anybody's software
yeah I would like if you use my software
because I think it makes trading easy
but you know if you're using Sierra
chart or if you're using you know the
ninja Trader plane orderflow that comes
with the paid version you could look for
these things okay but I'm going to show
you how to make it a lot more easy right
and you're going to see how easily and
quickly you could apply orderful
analysis to your trading to make better
trades you know don't take it from me
you know I'm biased but you know what
other customers have been saying is you
know the software my order flow Trader
software is very helpful because I can
clearly see now what's really happening
in the market okay so before we begin
just a brief
disclaimer risk capital is money that
could be lost without jeopardizing your
financial security or lifestyle okay and
remember only risk Capital should be
used for trading and only those with
sufficient risk Capital should consider
trading you know yesterday this is the
e- minis all the charts in this
presentation are from
yesterday this was the big selloff right
it was a massive sell-off yesterday um
and did you ever stop and think think
where the information that you look at
your chart comes from well it comes from
the time in sales right and this is what
most people think orderflow is about oh
you got to stare at the time and sales
or oh you got to stare at a dome right
but you know to be honest time and sales
move super fast right even a dome moves
very fast for a lot of people and you
know the way I describe having these you
know staring at these things either the
Dome or time in sales is like being in a
casino watching the slot machine
watching the wheels of a slot machine go
around you get excited oh the Market's
moving I got to get involved oh you know
S&P is just jump two points I got to I
got to do something I got to buy you
know or I got to sell and you're going
to find yourself in a lot of Trades you
shouldn't be in because you're getting
over excited again it's like being in
having a slot machine on your dealing
desk your trading desk
now the problem though right with time
and sales as well as the dome right the
dup the market the price ladder whatever
you want to call it it's just that it
moves too fast for Traders to understand
what's really happening in the market
right it just becomes a blur it's just
moving so
fast so what's the difference between
time and sales in a bar chart well the
bar chart just shows the price that
traded right that's all right that's all
it does it just shows you oh the market
opened here this was the high this was
the low this is where it closed doesn't
show you the
volume time in sales shows the price
traded and the volume traded and more
importantly the side of the market it
traded on right so remember go back to
yesterday right we had this little rally
right just after the cash open we sold
off got this little bimp bump up here
some people thought oh this is a great
buying opportunity I got to buy it here
then the market continued to sell off
you know another 50 50 points all right
so this is that little area there in the
Box magnified okay if you're just
looking at this you know you know
imagine you're just looking at a bar
chart you think oh I got a pin bar here
that's bullish you know I got some green
bars all that's that's bullish this
Market's going up but if you're watching
the order flow what you're seeing is
actually even though the market is
starting to go up a bit you know it's
rallied from 43 up to 48 nice fiveo M
rally little rotation there you're
seeing bullish things in the order flow
right you're seeing aggressive selling
coming in you're seeing Market sweeps
you're seeing Market weakness come
in that's what the order flow is going
to tell you so you could be instead of
thinking that you know I should be
buying it in here instead you should be
looking to short
it so before we begin you know just
basic background on
orderflow what exactly is orderflow and
why is it important well most Traders
view the market just on a simple
Candlestick chart right here on the left
right oh this is where we opened up here
at 39 A5 we had a low of 38
3/4 um we closed at 39 and a quarter
simp now an orderflow Trader views the
market well yeah we we opened up at
395 um most of the volume went through
at 39 and a quarter we did trade 38 3/4s
very small volume there's a little bit
of buying that came in at off the low
you got a buying and balance there
that's that's how orderflow Traders view
the market it's a bit different than you
know your normal Candlestick
chart excuse me
so most Traders just view the market oh
we open here you know they look at well
you know hey we opened in this bar and
we closed here next bar was a little bit
higher higher high just like that right
it's kind it's
two-dimensional the information that you
see on the bar chart right on your
normal bar chart there it comes from the
time and sales but it's leaving out the
most important part of the data that's
available to you and that's the volume
that's traded on the bid and the volume
that's traded on the offer right again
you know all you're looking at is just
what traded on where the market opened
where it closed what the high and the
low was it it's disregarding all the
volume and that's very important that's
very valuable information to a
Trader and again this is how an
orderflow Trader will view the market
they'll look at what the volume was on
the
bid what the volume was on the offer the
relationship in the two-way
auction they're going to be looking to
see you know are aggressive buyers in
control or aggressive sellers in control
you know are is just mostly aggressive
buying or mostly aggressive selling
there's so much
information that can be derived from
this simple elegant footprint chart you
know and again you know like I say 99%
of Traders aren't looking at it the 1%
are they're getting you know they're
they're getting so much information out
of
here so again the bar chart just shows
the price that traded but that's just
the starting point an orderflow chart
shows the price traded and the volume
but more important ly the volume traded
on the bid and the volume traded on the
offer it tells you the direction of the
market through aggression remember
markets trade in a two-way auction there
is a bid which are buyers and there is
an offer which are the sellers these
Traders are called passive Traders but
for a trade to
happen someone needs to buy the offer or
a Trader needs to sell the bid when a
Trader does that he is considered the
aggressor right they're called aggressor
Traders so imagine Market is five bit at
six no trade's going to happen unless
somebody that's bidding at five goes up
to six or someone trying to sell it at
six goes down to
five you know if it's five bit at six
and you're just sitting on the bid or
you're just sitting on the offer you're
considered a passive
Trader now again you know Traders paid a
lot of money to be on the trading floor
so they could trade off of this
information right they can see where the
where the orders are coming from is it a
big bank is it you know just some retail
company that you know some retail broker
has just got a small order you know all
this all volume
matters now here's the time in sales
okay and it gives you so much
information problem is it moves so fast
so you can see down here at the blue the
market is currently 36 86 and a quarter
bid offered at 3686 a half offer how can
I tell you know do you ever wonder why
some of these are green some are red or
in this case
orange when it's green it's telling you
someone was lifting the offer someone
was buying the offer when it's red or in
this case Orange it's telling you
someone was selling into the bid so if I
see red I know someone is selling into
that bid right so I know the bid is 3686
and a
quarter if I see green I know someone
was buying from the offer someone was
lifting the offer right so I know the
offer is 36 862 because it's trading 862
and it's green so that means someone's
buying that
offer now here the market went right in
here where this yellow arrow is it went
from 86 A2 offer to 862 bid how do I
know it's because it was green so
someone was buying the offer here it was
offered at 86 and a half now all of a
sudden someone is selling it at 86 and a
half that means the market has turned
bid okay so it's 86 and a half bid right
now 86 and A2 at 86 and
3/4 if this is you know a one tick
spread but what happened is all of a
sudden you went you know someone bought
a bunch of 86 and a halfs turned it bid
then a seller came in sold the 86 halves
sold the 86 and a
quarters all the way down to you know 86
even right they turned it 86 even offer
right here okay now someone know in this
one second someone came in and bought
one you know there's sort of you know as
you know markets moveed so fast you know
as the person was selling it at uh 86
and a half 86 and a quarter someone
bought
one but I can see here you know someone
you know started hitting the 86s even
here now again this is time in sales
this is all within one second right and
there's actually more trades but this
gives you an idea if you're looking at
time in sales you're not going to be
able to make heads or tails of it it's
all happened so fast again this is all
within one second you know it goes from
86 and a
qu offer all the way up to 86 and 3/4
offer back down to
86 so you know Traders realize there's a
lot of information there on the time in
sales but it's just too difficult to
make heads or heads or tails out of
right they needed an easyto read format
so you know they came up with the
footprint chart I didn't invent the
footprint chart you know there's other
Traders before me that did and you know
God bless them because it's such a big
help to Traders
nowadays takes all that information here
that you can that you see trading and
puts it all in here so it's easy to read
right and and you can make heads and
tails of it you can make sense of it you
can make sense of the
market so once you organize that data
based on how it's traded you have a lot
of data points to analyze and the three
building blocks of order flow is Delta
point of control and imbalances Now
Delta is the difference between
aggressive buying and aggressive selling
point of control is the price level on
the bar with the most volume right every
bar is going to have a Delta every bar
is going to have a point of control now
imbalances is what happens in the bar
right it's what happens um you know when
you have aggressive buyers outnumbering
aggressive sellers by four to one or
more or vice versa right so it's telling
you what's happening in the two-way
auction you know the
Delta is the final
number um between aggressive buyers and
aggressive selling in a bar point of
control is simply just the price level
with the most volume but imbalances it's
what's happening inside the bar and why
is this important is
because as the market is selling off
Delta is generally going to be negative
right because it's telling you
aggressive sellers are in control in
each bar now of course you'll have one
or two bars in there sometimes that go
opposite but in generally when markets
rally you're going to see nice positive
Delta you know normally most orderflow
charts we'll put it along the bottom so
it's easy to read you know you sometimes
you don't want too much stuff all over
your
chart again point of control is the
price level in a bar with the most
volume and an orderflow chart will have
it you know highlighted there usually in
a gray rectangle every bar has one I
highlighted a few I didn't highlight all
of them and why is it important
because have you ever wonder why a bar
retraces to a certain level okay it just
seems you know Bar opens rallies up you
can see here you know just rallies up
comes to this gets within a tick of this
point of control and then sells off
because that's where the volume was
that's where everyone was happy to trade
that's sort of in a sense in a crude
sense the value of this bar right the
fair price of this bar is right there
okay even here right we opened up
rallied up right to that point of
control you know here we opened up
higher came within a tick or two of this
point of control here we opened up right
on the point of control went higher and
you can look through charts you can see
how how well these hold over time now
imbalances is a good way to determine
the direction of the market right if
you're going to see a lot of selling
imbalances in a
bar that's these red numbers are selling
imbalances or blue numbers in a bar
those are buying imbalances okay and
it's going to help tell you that the
direction of the market okay so imagine
right you you you oh this Market sold
off it's got this little balance I'm
going to get short here but then all of
a sudden you see a lot of buying
imbalances that's not a good sign if
you're
short just as you know if you got long
you know somewhere earlier in this bar
than you know underneath where you got
long you started seeing a lot of selling
imbalances that's not a good sign right
that's how order flow is going to help
you determine um you know a whether you
should still be in the trade or B you
know if conditions have changed in the
market now
imbalances are caused in the two-way
auction so you can see here right
there's 14 against 139 in this green bar
right here 14 against 139 that's almost
10 to one that's like 9.8 to1 that's an
imbalance 6 against 43 that's an
imbalance now 19 against
56 is not a
4:1 uh percentage right a ratio
of uh 400% so you could actually adjust
what you want to use as your um
imbalanced
threshold but you know most people use 4
to one and you know that's good starting
point for most people now think of it
this way difference between bar chart
orderflow chart
is a piece of pizza right that's your
bar chart yeah that's nice you could eat
you could live off a bar chart okay but
it's just showing you what traded at
price
orderflow is the whole pizza so why
settle for just a slice when you could
have the whole pizza right you get a
more complete picture of what's
happening in the market you know maybe
you don't want that slice there you want
the slice on the other side it's up to
you you know there's so much more you
can do rather than just being confined
to one slice now having all that
orderful information is nice right you
can see how the market traded but this
is 21st century right it's not the 1980s
you know on a DOS
screen you know where you're just
looking at uh you know Amber colors or
you know those those funky old orange
colors um computers can do a lot for a
Trader now right for me I like all sorts
of stuff on my pizza right I just want
just cheese I want olives I want sausage
I want Tomatoes I want peppers I want
more cheese that's why I created the
order FL Trader software I basically
take a plain pizza it made it taste
better right there's nothing wrong with
a plain cheese pizza don't get me
wrong but it's plain right just like
most orderflow software out there it's
plain I took it a step further when I
created the orderflow software because I
was trading with orderflow myself and I
realized what the hell am I doing you
know after I left JP Morgan where I got
you know so much computing power at my
fingertips you know and I'm training for
myself I'm like gosh you know why are we
using software that just shows you what
the volume was traded on the bid and the
offer just the Delta just the point of
control just the
imbalances um you know I want to see
where buyers and sellers are getting
stronger or weaker where the Market's
potentially
reversing who's in control of the market
right orderflow Trader takes all that
information you see in the time in sales
and depth of the market and transforms
it into an easyto read understand foot
uh chart right this is just your normal
plane footprint chart it's already got a
lot of data which is good good you know
for for experienced Traders traders that
have been watching orderflow for a long
time yeah you can deal with that but if
you're sort of newer to orderflow or you
want to sort of turbocharge your your
trading you know that's why I created my
software is because I wanted to take my
trading to another level right I didn't
have the resources that I had when I was
working in Banks or trading firms you
know I could just pick up a phone call
somebody you know they could you know
run analysis for me do all sorts of
stuff
I wanted my software my trading software
to show me market weakness to show me
support resistance to show me when a
market was being swept when there was
imbalance where there was value where
there was aggressive trading and so much
more so this is the order Trader
software with you know some of the
things highlighted now I can see where
there's Market weakness now I can see
where there's support and resistance now
I can see you know where there's a lot
of imbalances in a bar where there's
Market being being swept in the you know
when there's someone is sweeping the
market right in here and you know that's
what you want as a Trader right you want
to have as many Tools in your toolbox as
possible to make your trading easier
now the reason why I talk about the
order FL Trad is because I want you to
see how easy reading the orderflow can
be when you have the right tools right
and basically that's just having the
right software you're going to be able
to see who's in control of the market
how to be in sync with the market and
understand why the markets stop and
reverse so we all have you ever stopped
to think what makes the market go up or
down people are going to say support and
resistance well not really it's the
aggressive Traders it's the traders in
the market that cause the market to go
up or down and precisely it's the
aggressive Traders the passive Traders
don't right they're just happy to sit on
the bid happy to sit on the offer they
create support and resistance but it's
the aggressive traders that cause the
markets to go up or
down but how can you see aggressive
trading on a bar chart you can't it
appears on the time in sales but who
wants to look at time in sales all day
you'll go blind the easiest way is to
look for imbalances in the footprints
now these are just a couple of little
bars here right you can see selling IM
balances are red in the bar that's these
red numbers in the
bar that's buying and balances are the
blue numbers in the bar okay now when
people start looking at a footprint
chart they get scared because there's so
many numbers people are scared of
numbers people hate math in general okay
but what I'm telling you is you don't
have to analyze every single trade that
goes through you're just looking for
certain things in the order flow and one
of them is
imbalances so first I'll talk about
buying imbalances okay now bars have
buying imbalances they have selling
imbalances
okay alone by itself it may not mean
anything but when you start to put them
together in context of the market then
you could understand what's happening in
the market and you can see as this
Market is rallying we're seeing a lot of
buying imbalances this Bar's got three
this Bar's got three this Bar's got two
you know this Bar's got six here right
as you just had this nice rally this is
crude from yesterday we went from
basically
4870 all the way up to
4895 and if you're watching imbalances
you could have seen yeah you know you
we're starting to see a lot of buying
imbalances okay that's
bullish
so most Traders are use orderflow are
familiar with imbalances okay and
they're most familiar with stack buying
imbalances and that's what this green
area is where you have you know three or
more imbalances stacked on each other
that that's nice but this buying
imbalances coming after you just had the
25 cent move that's not very helpful to
you right you just moved 25 cents and
you got stack buying IM balance well
what what good is
that what you want to be you want to be
alerted much earlier right and you can
see here these bars have these pink
boxes around them these are bars with
multiple imbalances now they're green
bars with multiple buying imbalances
this we call multiple buying imbalance
bars and imagine if you're just looking
for stacked
imbalances well it's coming up here
after the move often times you're going
to see imbalances coming in in bars that
are not neatly stacked on top of each
other maybe they're spread out you know
a tick or two at every price level but
if you're looking for bars with multiple
imbalances you could catch the move a
lot
earlier now selling imbalances it's the
same thing but in opposite so you can
see 18 against four right that's a
selling of balance that's more than four
to one obviously zero against 27 5
against 27 here in the southern bar
three against 34 is like 10 to one 3
against 19 is what about 6
to1 6 against 42 is um 7 to1 14 against
is you know about uh about 5 to one
those are selling IM balances the black
numbers are just your normal order flow
going through right it's not an
imbalance it's just the market
facilitating
trade so you can see here selling
imbalances right here's this bar has got
three this Bar's got four this Bar's got
two as the market starts selling
off now here you got a nice stacked
selling balance you got three selling IM
balances stacked neatly on top of each
other one two three okay that's great
and the market sold
off but if you are training to look for
bars that have more than three
imbalances but are not neatly stacked on
top of each other you could get into
this move a little bit earlier here's a
bar with 1 two 3 4 right how do we know
it's got that box around it simple right
you don't have to make trading so
complicated that you need bells and
whistle all you need to be alerted to
hey you know what we're going sideways
but aggressive sellers have coming in
here we're seeing multiple buying uh
selling and B balances coming in okay
Market starts to break yeah I get short
here 4880 goes all the way down to 50
right you don't need to sit here oh well
now I got this selling a balance it's
coming in you know 5 cents lower 10
cents lower that you're getting short at
right it's going to give you a better
entry because you're going to be alert
to what's happening in the market as
soon as it
happens now imbalance stacked imbalance
multiple imbalance bars they occur in
just about every market and every time
frame so here's the e- mini one minute
chart this is in the middle of the night
last night okay this is 1:00 a.m.
Chicago time European open okay you see
a lot of buying and balances yeah that's
nice to
see you have nice stack buying and
balance here yeah that's great the
market went up but you could have been
alerted you know three points three
points not three ticks three points
earlier down here with the multiple
buying and balances you just got to know
what to look for right again you know
trading is is not so complicated that
you know Traders like to make things
complicated for some reason just look
for the simple things in the market now
that's not to say go out and buy every
bar that's got three or more multiple
buying imbalances or sell every bar
that's got three or more selling
imbalances but you know you got to still
put it in context but it's going to give
you you know trade opportunities that
other people just don't
see here's e min's yesterday 9:45 right
we got this bar right here you
everyone's going to see this big down
red candle oh that's bearish I got to
get short getting short down in here so
I don't know 3718 but right before that
big bar down the bar that went from 25
all the way down to 18 or 17 you had a
bar here you got this little bar with a
lot of selling imbalances three selling
imbalances so tell me would you rather
be short from up here at 24 25 or short
from down here at 17 18 of course you
should want to be short from you know
seven or eight points higher right and
that's how looking at multiple
imbalances in a bar can get you into
trades much sooner right everyone like I
said everyone's going to see oh you
knowy we broke out this low here got the
big red candle yeah it's good short here
but you can you know what Market's
looking weak right here I could short
this you know my stop is just going to
be right up here above 28 I'm getting
short at 25 a nice three-point stop
rather than getting short you know 1718
and having a stop you know twice as
big here's gold right like I said
multiple imbalan bars appear in all
markets right Market's selling off right
you're
seeing here's a red bar with multiple
selling IM balances they're not stacked
here you got your stacks onell on a
balance Market went a bit lower then
right off your swing low right here we
got one two 3 four buying in balances
Market went sideways before it started
popping back up again you know a move
from you know 38 all the way up to 41 41
A2 right and it came well before the
stack buy imbalance appeared in
here here's crude oil one minute chart
knowing where the imbalances are are
going to keep you on the right side of
the market so you know here you got some
bars with multiple buying imbalances no
stacked imbalances right the only
stacked selling imbalance or imbalance
for that matter is right here okay in
this bar you don't see any stack buying
and balances here here or here but what
you see
is a bar with multiple imbalances a bar
with multiple buying imbalances followed
by a bar with multiple selling
imbalances
imagine you know you're long okay you
get oh you know I got bar multiple
imbalances you get long okay that's good
I'm going to stay long then you start
seeing this bar is forming you're
starting to see already three selling
imbalances that's not a good sign even
though they're not stacked but if you're
watching the order flow
you know if you're getting long in here
at 40 what 4790 you know where do you
put your stop you put your stop you know
this might be a bit wide but you know 47
um 70 4765 somewhere in here the point
of control here is like 70 this low I
think was 65 64 you know maybe you hide
behind these two levels but then you see
this big bar down with multiple sell
balances oh you get out right you're
along from 90 you're trading 80 but you
got very bearish order flow that's your
sign to get out get out at 80 rather
than getting out at 65 or 60 you get out
of the trade you can cut your risk
almost in
half so imbalances are one way to see
aggressive traders in the market but
there are other ways to see aggressive
trading which may not be revealed by
imbalances so the other form I want to
talk about is Market sweeps now you know
people think that oh Market sweeps are
something new in the market no they've
been going on for ages and you know most
people don't think of it um because they
just don't have the experience right and
actually the old NX comx electronic
trading system um which is called access
had a feature on there this is back in
the the mid90s where it was called
Market sweep okay and say you know the
gold market was 1891
bid and you know you're a big seller you
just want to sell everything right now
you got 100 contracts to sell the gold
at 6:00 in the morning and you can see I
could sell 100 you look at the the dome
right the price ladder you say oh I
could sell 100 all the way down to
um 1890 so you just put it in 1890 you
sweep you hit all the bids boom you're
filled just like that and a market sweep
occurs when aggressive buyer lifts the
offer and the next best offer is behind
it or an aggressive seller hits the best
bid and the next bids below it so how
does that look right on time and sales
right this is what happened right this
pink area
the market was 862 bid someone came in
sold it all the way down to 86 right now
that was just um two price levels but
that's a sweep right they they cleared
out the 50s cleared out the 25s and
they're working Double
O's now on a price ladder right you will
see oh the Market's 86 and a quarter bid
below it 86 below it's 85 and 3/4 um
below it 85 and half and you'll see well
I got 500 to sell okay well I'm going to
sweep it from 86 and a quarter all the
way down to 86 and a half right it take
it down about a point okay so what the
person the trader would do is they would
enter sell
500 down to and with the price as 85 a
half right even though we're trading six
and a quarter six and a half the price
that they're willing to sell it all the
way down to is 85 and a half people say
well no they don't do that they
do that I've done it all my colleagues
do it right and the reason is we want to
get into the market as soon as possible
we think the Market's about to move and
we don't want to miss anything okay so
yeah okay I could get about 500 sold all
the way down to five and a half and when
I'm five and a half I get the residual I
think people will come in and and lift
the offer and there might be some orders
iceberg in there again if you're a big
Trader you're not concerned with oh I
got 52 or 89 here or 163 you're just
concerned with your average price right
if I'm a big Trader
I got a lot to
sell I book my trades at the average
price not the individual levels
but I know that my order if I hit the
when it hits the market is going to move
the market it's going to shift
perception of the market that's why they
come in and sweep so even though I sweep
from 6 and a quarter down to 5 and a
half most of my my average price is
probably going to be around 85 and 3/4
the Market's now 85 and a half offer 85
and a quarter
bid okay and and I'm my average is 85
and 3/4s you know happy days for me
because now the market based on my
expert trading analysis is going to go
lower so like my average price is 85 and
3/4 we're now trading 85 and a quarter
85 and a half alos come in hit the bit
at 85 and a quarter next thing you know
it's it's offered at 85 even that's how
the markets
work now imbalances highlight areas of
aggressive activity and a market sweep
is also a form of aggressive activity
but doesn't always mean it's an
imbalance right here you can see there's
Market sweeping occurring right here yes
you have imbalances because obviously
you got zero one
zero anytime you got zeros in a bar it's
going to cause generally an imbalance
but you can see here here's some
sweeping activity early in this bar
right you can see you know 25 traded
here 22 against 8 40 against 10 so you
know you highlighted a bit earlier in
this previous bar with the market sweep
and with the imbalances and then you're
getting further confirmation that yeah
this Market should be selling off nicely
right and it did right it sold off from
the 80 area all the way down you know to
70s it's crude oil one minute chart
imagine if you knew where a big fat
Trader was sweeping through the order
book well now you can right this is one
of my favorite pictures you'll sweep the
leg anytime someone would you know say
you sweep the book you say I'll sweep
the leg but um you can right if your
software is going to highlight it why
can't you have software that's going to
highlight it to you that's what I wanted
when
I was trading with orderflows like you
know what rather than me staring at the
chart all day looking sign is this or
isn't it you know let the software
highlight it to you here here there's
two Market sweeps in the book right this
is right here right this second sweep
right here where it's coming in around
the 4840 area this is what happened
immediately afterwards right we dropped
yesterday remember crude we sold off
about 100 points 100 ticks almost you
know instantly you don't see multiple
imbalances in here you don't see stacked
imbalances here right even in this bar
you see multiple imbalances but this is
the bar you want to be short on again
this is a one minute chart imagine
you're getting short here 4830 somewhere
in here 4825 even then two bars later
it's trading 4750 4 770 you know those
are the trades as Traders you love the
ones that just soon as you get short
Market moves in that direction and it
moves there quickly right you don't want
these you
know me I'm impatient right I like my
trades to start moving pretty quick
pretty soon okay and and that's where
having the right tools can help you as a
Trader zero currency now you can see
here right Market's just going sideways
someone start coming in order came in
and swept now again don't get all
excited and think oh you know there's
sweeping here there sweeping I got to
get long I get short you know take it in
context of the market and what's
happening overall again you know if you
be getting short in here 92 93 it made
its nice move down to you know 83 nice
10 ticks in the euro currency again one
minute chart yesterday so Market sweeps
and stacked imbalances can and do
overlap because they're both very
aggressive Market Behavior where it gets
juicy is when when a sweep occurs and
there's no stacked imbalance because
most Traders are looking for stacked
imbalances but practically no one is
looking for Market sweeps right this is
gold yesterday now gold is a thinner
Market than say e- minis or crude so
you're going to want to adjust the the
sweeping settings a little bit but you
could see here
right came down into this low very
aggressive buying going on in the form
of Market sweeps right this whole bar is
basically someone just came in and
started buying it off you know 42 A2 all
the way up to 44 A2 and then we went all
the way up to 47 and A2 some more
bearish sweeping came in here down from
you know 46 a half down to 44 some
bullish sweeping came in all the way
back up to 46 bearish 45 a half down
back down to 44 so again you know there
are settings you can adjust depending on
the market so hopefully you can see how
following what the aggressive Traders
are doing it's going keep you on the
right side of the market you know
imagine again you know if you're getting
long up in here right say oh you had
this nice move up I got to get long you
know all my indicators are are turning
bullish I gotta get long I get long up
here at 47 soon as you get long you see
a market Sweep come in you think this
Market's going to go keep going higher
yeah it might but the odds are that it's
going to go lower and then it starts
selling off ah you know what you get out
and then you get short oh I just had a
bear sweep I got get short you get short
down you know somewhere down in here at
44 and a half but then you start seeing
bullish activity you see a bullish Sweep
come in okay yeah I I better cut it now
you know cut my losses small you don't
want to let this go all the way back up
here oh I got to get out here at 46 and
a half 46 you know I get out you know a
dollar earlier right it's that's what's
talks about when I that's what I mean
when I say stay on the right side of the
market right let the order flow tell you
you the direction of the market either
through imbalances or Market sweep right
being in sync with the market is is what
you want to do as a Trader you know I
hate to use the term in CAD Shack be the
ball right be the market because
remember aggressive Traders are the ones
who move the market for a market to go
up aggressive buyers need to outnumber
the passive sellers for a market to go
down aggressive sellers need to
outnumber the passive buyers aggressive
trading will show up in the order flow
in several different pie is a Delta of
data the Delta imbalances the bid volume
and the ass volume but you know who
wants to really get that finite you know
get out the uh magnifying glass and
start analyzing this volume against that
volume let tools do it for you you know
and Market sweeps trading in the
direction of the market is just one way
to approach the market orderflow also
allows you to see the market turning
points because when a market reverses a
move that's a tremendous opportunity for
you why why is because the perception of
the market can have completely changed
right don't get don't get so caught up
into a bias that you can't change you
know like I said yesterday someone I
knows had a bias to belong this Market
belong the snps and they got hammered
they bought lost got bought again and
got lost because they had a bias rather
than just following what the orderflow
was telling them so another way to use
order flow is to find potential Market
turning points based on on the volume
and more importantly where it appears in
the bar now in most bars volume is
generally distributed in a bell-shaped
curve meaning most of the volume trades
around the center you know midpoint of
the bar more or less not
always but you know most bars do that
okay but in order flow you can see where
the most volume occurred okay the price
level were the most volume trades is
called the point of control the PLC not
every bar has a point of control and
most of the time it's somewhere near the
middle of the bar so last night this is
the daily bar chart of S&P
yesterday why did we could come all the
way up to that level and stop and turn
well this is where it was on a one
minute chart on a footprint chart okay
yeah you see well yeah I got selling IM
balances but again um what else do you
see well you see most of the volume
majority of the volume the most I say
majority but the level where most of the
volume occurred is right up here near
the top right then the market came down
went back up where did we trade we
traded right back up to that level right
we got a nice triple top here one two
three and
again where's the most volume these two
bars have it right here at 73 again we
came up here we traded 73 and a quarter
you got some decent volume up here
before the market started going sideways
and then selling off so there's going to
be times where the point of control
right the price level with the most
volume appears at or near the edge of a
bar and that means something usually
it's resting liquidity which is a big
order right we all you know some Traders
are familiar with um a book map or a
heat map which shows resting liquidity
in the
market and you know they sort of build
their whole trading plan around resting
liquidity point of control will also
show you that resting liquidity right
it's the stopping volume right it's a
big order in the market and in orderflow
I call that Prominent Point of control
which is basically a point of control
that acts as support or resistance now
remember every bar has a point of
control but not every point of control
means something right that's why
orderflows Trader highlights the point
of controls that matter right The
prominent points of control and you can
see here right here was a bullish sorry
a bearish Prominent Point of control you
had a bullish one here right and you'll
notice the market sold off from here
came down here went back up to the
bearish pro point of control came down
it was holding for a little while
eventually it broke this is going to be
your prominent points of control are
going to be Market generated information
which gives you real time support and
resistance levels you know that's formed
by the market it's telling you you know
as we were going up there was a big
bidder here right as we came up to the
high the day there's some selling
activity there doesn't have to
necessarily be passive it could be
passive and aggressive okay this is the
e- minute mini on a f minute
chart this this is your Prominent Point
of control that happened right up here
at one tick off the high and again you
can see where did we come off we came
off we rallied back up we got within one
tick of that Prominent Point of control
right here
right this is your resistance
level this is B the 10 years the ZN
and the thing about order flow is
sometimes there's some markets that seem
to follow order flow a heck of a lot
better than other markets and I always
say you know sort of these
um markets that are not cash settled
meaning they're deliverable tend to
follow support and resistance a bit
better than cash settled markets because
the the way the market is designed you
know people got to actually take
physical delivery of it you know and
bonds and tens are um physical
physically deliverable um so they tend
to follow support and resistance in my
opinion a bit better than some of the
cash settled markets like um e minis you
know NASDAQ micros
Etc look at this 10 years right you know
10 years is is one of the most liquid
markets in the world in terms of volume
on the bid volume on the offer and you
can see here right off the low of the
day yesterday you got a nice Prominent
Point of control that's your support
level look at that move straight up
right off that right that was just you
know the market just stopped right there
now the problem with the 10 years
is it's not very volatile people get
bored to death watching this because
there's just so much size sometimes it
takes a lot to get through I mean look
at this bid there was 19,000 ah had to
get through here here's 18,000 here's
20,000
12,000 that's what it's like when when
you're trading 10 years now bonds is a
little bit moves you know less volume
and move has a bit more price movement
same with ultra bonds but you can see
here yesterday just from 6:00 in the
morning until 9:00 in the morning
you had a bearish prim point of control
to a bullish up to a bearish a nice sell
off down to a bullish P point of control
and I move back up you can see how
they're holding holding holding holding
back
up crude oil yesterday this is just
after 8:30 in the morning big buyer
right here 4820 right big move
up there's crude oil a little bit later
in the day 4740 we eventually sold off
if you remember we had that big drop in
crude um but then boom Market's going up
comes right back you know gets this
little swing High comes pulls in a
little bit does this little rotation and
stops right here where you got some
heavy volume some stopping volume to
stop the move down there's buyers here
so it's telling you that's bullish right
and the market started going back up
again right that's how using letting the
computer letting the software analyze
the order flow for you to tell you yeah
this is bullish or yeah this is bearish
or yeah we have support or resistance
based on what's trading in the market
right now right you don't need the
market to come all the way back up from
4740 all the way back up to 4770 say oh
yeah there's support here you know as
soon as it comes here as soon as this
bar closes you're looking at that you
know put you know from 1040 onwards if
it's 1039 you see that yeah okay I got
some support I could buy it somewhere in
here could have just a stop just right
below this support area because I know
that that's my Line in the Sand if we
get past this the whole reason for being
in the trade is over I could get out
rather than waiting you know most people
wait for you to break out of this high
up here at 47 58 to get long to confirm
that yeah you know there is support here
well why wait get long here at
47 47 rather than
4757 you know full 10 points earlier
yeah you're just going to risk eight
ticks seven ticks you know it's going to
help you get into trades
earlier so another way to see when a
market could potentially be putting in a
bottom or top which is going to result
in a reversal is by spotting Delta
shifts okay so remember Delta is one of
the three Foundation blocks right
there's Delta there's imbalances and
there's point of control right I've
talked about imbalances I've talked
about point of control now I'm going to
talk about Delta right and Delta is the
difference between aggressive buyers and
aggressive
sellers so if you have positive Delta
it's telling you aggressive buyers are
in control right if you have negative
Delta is telling you aggressive sellers
are in control and as markets rise a bar
is going to generally have positive
Delta as markets fall generally it's
going to have negative Delta not always
there there's cases where it's the
opposite and that's a whole another
webinar I've done presentations on that
um but this is crude oil yesterday okay
I crude moved nicely yesterday a lot of
markets had nice moves yesterday but
imagine this Market's going up you sort
of get in here you know you're thinking
yeah if you're long you're thinking yeah
this is great we're going to go back up
hit
4850 or you know instead what happened
is the market sold off from 48 bucks
back down to
4730 okay so you know imagine you're
getting long here at 4770 you're going
up you're looking for a move up to 4850
then the market starts dropping right
you got your stop down here you're long
at 70 maybe you got a stop you know
below here at
4750 okay 20 ticks
well why let it stop you out if you
could read what was happening in the
order flow how it turned bearish in here
you could get out earlier again you'd be
getting out at 4780 with a small profit
you're long from 70 you're getting out
at 80 wise because yeah you're in the
money but the order flow now is turned
bearish why let it come all the way down
to your stop price and stop you out for
a full loss that's what I have
scratching my head you know people
people sometimes think that oh you know
I'm either going to be right or wrong
well you could still be
right in and wrong at the same time well
you're right that the market went up you
could book a small profit then you're
wrong that it broke down why is because
while there was bullish order flow on
the way up it changed in here right it
became
bearish and by watching the Delta
especially when you're in a position
helps you understand the direction of
the market right if you're long and the
market is kind of stalling right the
Delta is negative that's a sign that the
market could be getting heavy and it's
ready for a drop right not only are
aggressive sellers in control but also
more importantly for the market to go up
you need aggressive buying and if the
market is not showing you aggressive
buying it's probably not going to go
higher and this was that little area I
was just showing you on the crude right
you came all the way up from 4770 you're
trading 48 bucks but what do you see
right yeah I still got green bars it's
still bullish but you see
negative Delta minus 300 minus 50 um
minus two is nothing small could be
either way um so what I call a neutral
Delta - 184 - 159 - 262 okay well it
just happened you just went up from 70
up to 48 even but now selling is coming
in right selling continued here as we
went down but you're seeing it coming in
at sort of a swing high and it's mostly
negative selling that's what
distribution is right the market rall
okay now people are going to be
Distributing they're going to getting
out of their position they've got more
inventory to sell they're happy to sell
it on this little rise up that's your
sign that's where order flow is going to
make things a lot easier for you as a
Trader this is five years or sorry 10
years ZN on a FIV minute chart a little
confused there now you see the Market's
cominging down right hard negative Delta
-
12,000 negative Delta minus 4,000 yeah
you had some buying coming in here plus
4,000 which sort of wipes this out and
then a little bit of selling right minus
300 strong buying plus
7,000 a little bit of negative selling
400 little bit of positive then strong
buying 4,000 right so you just had this
big strong move down very strong selling
you know capped off by this minus 12,000
very little follow through now you're
seeing strong buying coming in here you
got multiple imbalances 1 2 three
imbalances okay very strong positive
Delta these two are kind of mixed up and
down plus 500-
400 but then plus 4,000 plus
3,000 okay you're not seeing the- 4,000
negative Delta you're not seeing the-
12,000 negative Delta instead it's
gained all that back and it's turning
positive right this is what happened
this is that area right in there on the
F minute chart
on that footprint chart in the F in the
10 years right if you're just looking at
a bar chart you're not going to see that
information then you had this nice move
up from 30 all the way up to 04 people
say oh that's not much of a move from 30
to 04 thing you don't understand right I
mean for a lot of Traders is you know a
lot of retail Traders just trade one lot
two lots three lots five maybe thing
about 10
years is since the market is so thick
there's a lot of people that like to
move size right so I know some people
they they trade 10 years they just trade
100 Lots 200 Lots they're just looking
for a few ticks two three ticks and
they're done right because they've
traded 200
contracts they only need to make two or
three ticks you know they're not in and
out scalping all day long on on the e-
minis or micros it's that's how
orderflow is going to help you right
depending on your type of trading
whether you're looking at scalping two
ticks or whether you're looking at
trading 500 contracts 300 contracts
so if you're short right I just showed
you some bullish ones if you're long or
how to get long but if you're short and
the Market's no longer moving lower and
just kind of hanging around you watch
the Delta if you start seeing positive
Delta remember you're short right you be
wanting to see negative Delta but if you
see positive Delta bars coming in that's
a sign that the market could be getting
tired and is ready for a rally right
aggressive sellers could be running out
of their bullets right they got no more
to sell right I was just showing you
that in the bonds lot of sellers minus
122,00 th000 Delta and then the next bar
you know minus 300 Delta yeah you had
one last final push minus 4,000 then
that was it all of a sudden you had
aggressive buying coming in positive
deltas and again that's going to give
you a lowrisk trade because if you buy
at right off the low I'm not trying to
predict the low I'm letting orderflow
tell me you know what there's no more
selling in here right just as in here
right we came down here- 12,000 oh
that's bearish minus 4,000 that's
bearish minus 300
plus 7,000 it's told me it's shifted the
perception of this Market the selling is
is gone right instead now I see some
strong positive bullish news in the
order flow right I don't see you don't
want to see- 12,000 - 400 more- 4,000
minus 300 and expect this Market to go
down then boom you see plus 7,000 in the
Delta you get long here at
28 okay where's your stop down here down
here you know 26 26 and a
half and then boom the market went up
because you don't see you know all those
sellers they're done selling right they
got no more inventory to sell got no
more reason they don't want to sell
anymore so that's how looking at Delta
is going to help you in trades this is e
minis right imagine you're short big
selloff boom boom boom we're coming down
36 70 we cleared out 3660 we cleared out
down in the 3850 3650 now and what do
you see
you see any strong negative Deltas yeah
well here's minus 200 okay but plus 200
plus 300 64 35- 161 still not really
going anywhere we're not going lower
someone's coming in now and absorbing
the selling you know they're they're
buying the bid you know the working bids
but they're also buying the offers right
when these sellers are offering it out
they're also buying it and then boom
nice strong positive Delta 300 nice
strong positive Delta 400 Market starts
rallying back up another 10 ticks and
again imbalances 1 2 three four got that
pink box around it again visual trading
is becoming visual nowadays right this
is what it looked like right Market's
coming off boom rally back up boom new
low not new lows but coming down into
these lows taking them out going
sideways well what's the market going to
do is it going to be pausing you know or
is it going to Rally well based on the
order flow in here it's
bullish why wouldn't you be buying it in
here why wouldn't you be buying it in
this bar right at 61 60 61 62 a quick
10-point move in 15
minutes so what I've showed you can be
done just by looking at any footprint
chart but you need to know what to look
for right I was just talking about Delta
shifts right but when the Market's
moving you know especially like
yesterday where it's down hard it's easy
to overlook and Miss because you're
looking at so many different things a
lot of people put all sorts of
indicators on their chart for whatever
reason often times they're not even
paying attention to them
anymore
but in hindsight it's easy to look back
and say oh yeah you know this you know
you could have got short here because
could got long there but if you have
software that's doing the heavy lifting
for you shows you things like Market
weakness or Market sweeps it's going to
put you ahead of everybody else trying
to figure it out manually and again
especially like yesterday if you're
trying to watch the time in sales forget
it it's moving super duper fast you the
average trade in the e- minis is like
two contracts okay and imagine how many
contracts trade in a minute right so if
you're trading one two
lots yeah it's going to be a lot on the
time in sales and you can't process that
information it's too difficult right but
what you want to do is you want to take
those pieces and put them in your head
now the oros trader chart is going to
show you Market weakness all right it's
one thing to have a footprint chart okay
maybe could read the Deltas and try to
make something out of it and hope you're
right you know have software that's
going to highlight you yes P you a blue
arrow telling you yes it's bullish here
you should be consider buying right and
Market weakness is like looking at the
gauge in your car of how much gas you
got left right is it on empty or is it
on full think of it in terms of market
movement is there still gas left in this
move can it go higher or are on empty
now there are two types of Market
weakness in terms of Delta there's
bearish Market weakness which occurs
when the market has been moving higher
but can't sustain the move higher the
buying is weakening now bullish Market
weakness yeah I understand it's an
oxymore on your way bullish Market
weakness how could you have bullish
weakness but what that means is the
market has been going lower but the
selling just tapers off and is exhausted
basically the selling is what's Happ is
getting weak not the buying it's the
selling that's been getting weak so
bullish Market weakness right Market's
been going down but the sellers are
getting less and less until the buyers
take control of the market the selling
is weakening so how can you tell you
watch the Delta see what's happening in
the
Delta so here you go right you can see
the Delta's positive negative negative
negative then turns positive and Market
rallies back up Here's your sign
orderful Trader will put a little arrow
there tell you hey what you know what
you got um
a bullish sign that the selling is kind
of weak down here get ready for a move
up you know here's another one this is
gold again you can watch the Delta try
and figure it out um you know is it
really getting weak or what you know and
try and guess but let software analyze
it for you so bearish Market weakness is
the opposite the Market's been going up
but the buying is weakening until
there's no more strong buyers right for
Market to go higher you need more strong
buyers you got to watch the delta you
got to be asking is the aggressive
buying getting stronger or weaker as the
market is going
up or in this case says the market is
going down well not really going down
this was uh crude oil yesterday right
the market was just sort of hanging
around in here and then boom you got
some signs of weakness coming in here
around the 4835
area and what happened next we had that
big drop from 48 you know came in here
again around the 4830 area all the way
down to the 4730 area
now there's two ways to do this all
right the easy way and the hard
way me personally I prefer the path of
least resistance I want to let the
computer show me what's happening in the
market right there's no point in
spending $1,000 $2,000 $3,000 for a
fancy computer or some software when you
still got to do all the analysis
yourself right and try and figure out is
this bullish or is this bearish you know
let the computer do it for you that's
why you invest money in trading software
and a trading computer so hopefully in
this past hour you'll agree that this
has been time well spent right hopefully
you're going to come away and you know
you could start applying some of what I
just taught you on your own trading
right in and if you already have a
footprint chart um you could apply some
of that if you're looking if you're
trading on a bar chart then you know I
got something special for you now I
can't cover everything in a 60 Minute
training session it's just impossible
there's so much um information I'm just
giving you a taste right a taste of what
you could be doing in your trading that
can make you a better
Trader so I got a special offer for you
on orderflow and I'll give you a very
special deal it's the orderflows trader
3.0 right which is the charts that you
saw in this presentation now it runs on
ninja Trader okay it doesn't run on
thinker swim it doesn't run on Sierra
chart it doesn't run on um station I use
ninja Trader because I'm a I'm a Futures
Trader okay that's
my wheelhouse so to speak um it's been
that way since I started in the industry
25 years ago and ninja Trader is stable
you know some people say oh it's not
stable and but they're using a computer
from five years ago you know nowadays
computers are so cheap you can get very
good computers for $500 even monitors
you pick up for 100 bucks 200 bucks not
even you can get nice 32in
monitor it's a volume footprint chart
the orderflow is Trader 3.0 but it has
17 pre-programmed orderflow tools I've
talked about a couple I've talked about
multiple imbalances I've talked about
Market sweeps I've talked about Market
weakness but there's a lot of other
tools in the orderflows trader 3.0
that's going to help your trading um
show you price exhaustion for example
show you value area show you value area
setups and the Beautiful part of the
orderflows trader 3.0 is it's very easy
to setup it's not one of these things
where you got to be spending an hour
going through the
setup the default setups are for an e-
mini one minute chart which is what most
people look at honestly you don't need
templates but if you do need a template
you know just message me I have even
Quick videos show you how easy it is to
set up a template really to set up
orderflows Trader 3.0 on ninja Trader
takes two minutes normally I sell this
for $8.99 and the orderflows trader what
it does is it takes my knowledge of
trading orderflow puts it into a program
so you can see what institutional
Traders are doing in the market it's
like having me sitting on a chair next
to you saying hey you know what taing on
the shoulder um you know Market is weak
up here or here's there's resistance
being formed but I realize having
orderflow software is one thing you need
to know how to use it right A lot of
people you buy you spend thousand
dollars on software and then you get it
and you got like five pages of
instructions I don't just give you
software and hey go on your way let you
figure it out no I'm going to give you a
lot of Education to show you not just
how to use a software
about how to trade with orderflow now I
have a course right it's called trading
orderflow there's 20 lessons in there
normally I sell this for $297 you're
going to get it today for
free you're also going to get access to
all the videos I created for the
orderflows Inner Circle there's 56
videos they're about 35 minutes to an
hour long of advanced orderflow trip t
tricks tips and Analysis okay you going
get all that for free so you can
understand a lot of the nuances and
special situations that you should be
looking for in the order flow and you
know you start adding this up you know
the software is $899 the training is$
297 the Inner Circle video series is um
$1,600 right that's that's a lot of
money but again you shouldn't have to
pay that much right and you're not going
to pay that much now you know the
problem with
trading you know trying to learn from
watching videos a lot of people like to
watch videos on YouTube and you know
figure I'll just learn from there trying
to figure out on your own is it's it's
hard right because you got to apply
yourself and what I found very helpful
is having live training where you can
come in ask questions now this is not a
live trade room right where I'm sitting
here Buy Here Sell there no you're not
going to learn that way I'm going to
give you each week Tuesday nights
today's a Tuesday there'll be session
tonight at 700 p.m. central Time is it's
a live user training session only open
for users of my software where I drive
home what I saw in the order flow for
the past week you can ask your questions
about areas you may be struggling with I
I show people how to you know adjust
their settings Etc depending on their
markets now I've been doing this for
over two years there's over hundred and
well there not there's over 100 episodes
102 um I've been off for the last two
weeks because of the holidays and you
could have access to all the replays now
I'm not going to expect everyone to go
watch 102 episodes but you know if you
you got time to kill and you're really
you know interested in learning more
about order flow it's a great way to
learn more about
orderflow and again if you can
attend you will get access to the replay
so other people other gurus out there
that sell software for a lot more charge
you to teach you how to use their
software for what you just dropped you
know a lot of money and then they want
to charge you extra to teach you how to
use it what the heck is that about right
people I've seen
other companies sell these software for
over $1,000 they want to charge you $200
a month to come into their you know
their their trade room or whatever and
show you how to use it no that's that's
ridiculous but people still do it so you
when you start adding all that up the
software the training the Inner Circle
video series The the weekly live
trainings you know that's almost that's
close to $2,000 but you're just going to
pay a one-time payment
$7.49 right you go to order flows.com
slof 3ht ml make sure you put the HTML
that's it $749 there's no recurring
payments you know I'm not one of these
guys that's going to be charging your
credit card bill forever and to cancel
the payment you got to go you know stand
upside down jump through hoops or
anything like that you know there's a
lot of people you know that they you
know I I trade right it's what I do for
a living um you know people they want to
sell you software as they they living
right they that's why they charge you
money monthly because they want to keep
having money coming in right because
they're not actually that's their
business is I'm going to just get more
people in pay me you know $100 a month
$200 a month and never offer a chance
for someone to say you know what I love
your software I want it just buy it
right instead they want to keep billing
people forever out infinum but there's
no other payments you got to make all
right upgrades the ninja the order flows
Trader we've done two major upgrades in
the last 5 years we do them about every
two years just did one recently um back
in October the upgrades free right even
if you um you know you come back to me
you know you buy it now and then you
don't use it for a year you come back to
me and we do an upgrade yeah you're
still going to get the upgrade for free
now the only thing you're going to need
to pay but it's not payments to me
obviously you got to pay data fees you
got to pay ninja Trader fees if you're
on the the paid version of ninja Trader
you got to buy that but the software
will work on the free version of ninja
Trader but again you know what other
people are saying is you know the
orderflows Traders helps them see what's
really happening in the market like
who's in control at a very specific time
and who's getting weaker right you know
another guy zad says you know if you
really want to trade properly and
understand what on Earth is happening in
any markets orderflow is the path
forward and Mike's experience and
explanation it clicks right again you
know I don't come here saying oh you
know I've traded my own account for five
years now I have the software you know
you should buy it this is what I did you
know I traded on a professional level
for over 20 years right that's how I
that's how I lived that's how I survived
that's how I paid my house that's how I
paid my car put food on the table is by
working in a trading firm right not
working as an accountant or working as
you know an engineer no offense to those
lines of profession but I traded for a
living I didn't have some other side
business or some other main business in
trading was a side business that's all I
did you know I hate to use the term eat
sleep trade but as soon as I walked out
of the office I didn't want to have
anything to do with it but um you know
from 6:00 in the morning until 6:00 at
night I was in the markets I was
involved in the markets trading
constantly so go to orderflows
docomo
three3 number three. HTML it takes you
to this page right you just scroll down
to the bottom of the page there's videos
you could watch and more
examples but you click on this button to
get started you know click here to buy
now you can see
$749 that's It lifetime access the
orderflows trader the training course
the Inner Circle video series The Weekly
live group trainings and it's takes you
to PayPal when you click on that little
red uh what's that orange yellow button
all right it takes you to PayPal I don't
get your credit card information I don't
want your credit card information it's
handled through
PayPal you pay in Bitcoin if you want
but you got to email me um and
after you make payment you know once
your payment is processed I'm going to
email you everything right the the
software show you how to download it um
you know your license information in
there your username and password for all
the courses so again it's just a
one-time payment
749 so you got a few choices right
option one you could do nothing stay
right where you are right now going in
circles okay and for some people that's
what happens they don't do anything and
you know they watch videos they watch my
presentations they don't do anything for
a year two years they just keep watching
videos trying to think they're going to
learn it on their own you know jump to
the front of the line you know let me
help you you know another option is you
could take what you learned today go out
there and see if you can do it on your
own you know trial and error for the
next few months perhaps if you're lucky
maybe you could see some positive
results right don't put the horse before
the cart put it after the cart you know
let me help you
number three take let me take you by the
hand and allow us to walk you step by
step through each part of the process
skip the trial and error right trial and
error costs money you people think well
I'm trying to figure out my own
meanwhile they're losing money more
importantly you're losing time you're
losing your life trying to figure it all
out if you do the work you'll watch as
your life and trading transforms right
before your eye so you have to figure
out which option is best for you try and
figure it on your own or do nothing or
let me help you right but you got to
figure out what motivates you
right what Freedom do you want what
Freedom you know have freedom to go
where you want freedom to do nothing you
know for some people doing nothing is
freedom you know this summer I went to
uh took the family we went to South
Dakota right we went to Mount
Rushmore and a few other places you know
that's what trading does it gives you
Freedom right it lets you say you know
what I don't want to work this week hey
let's uh pack up the car take a drive
someplace okay that's what you can do
when you're
Trader now as a special bonus for
investors Expo since they put this
together I also give you access to one
of my favorite courses The orderflow
Playbook right normally I sell this for
$297 you also going to get that for free
right but you got to get started now or
you got to go to orderflows docomo 3ht
ml so what you're going to get is the
orderflows trader
3.0 the orderflows trading course
orderflows Inner Circle video series
access to live weekly Group Training and
the orderflows Playbook right that's
well over $2,000 but you're going to get
it all for just a onetime payment of
$749 again no monthly recurring payments
or any other payments in the future now
if you stuck around and you're
interested in my
book go to orderflows docomo HTML I've
put the link in the chat so that you can
um easily find it you just got to enter
your name name and email address after
then hit
submit and it'll take you to the
download page when you enter orderflows
docomo
HTML um it's not going to be there you
have to enter your name and email
address so I know who you are that
you're a real person so you get access
to the book so get started now I mean
don't waste any more time you know it's
we've just really almost a year into
this pandemic and there's traders that
have done well trading in this pandemic
time you know people have been losing
their job and wondering what they're
going to do to support themselves or you
know just maybe looking for a little bit
extra income if you know you you figure
out a way to make orderflow work in your
trading plan or more importantly build
your trading plan around orderflow then
you know you're going to be ahead of all
the other Traders struggling to make it
out there so again I'm not going to make
promises that oh you're going to make a
million dollar next week you know it
takes work you know you have to put in
time you have to put in effort it's not
going to all just magically fall into
your lap you I'll give you an
example there was a time in my career
where I had to make a
decision you know basically my boss was
giving me the opportunity to start
trading and I was a little bit gun-shy
honestly you know I was like oh my gosh
there's a lot of money involved but I I
knew this is what I wanted to do and he
just said hey you Vos if you don't do it
I'm going to get so and so to do it so
you damn sure I started banging away on
the computer figuring it out you know
cuz you know you know as a person I I
don't like to make mistakes and mistakes
cost money when you're trading it's not
like you know working in a grocery store
nothing wrong with working in a grocery
store I did that when I was in college
you know in a grocery store you put you
make a mistake yeah you put the
cornflakes where the waties go in
trading you make a mistake it costs
money right and then nobody likes to
lose money because when you lose money
you feel like you're I say lesser of a
person but you know you don't feel good
even if it's not your money you know you
you'll still take it and feel the
emotions of it but unless you get
started and unless you get up off your
butt and start doing things you're never
going to see results period there's no
way around it so you know just a couple
quick questions that um come up will the
software work on trade station or S
charts no my software the orfs trader
works on ninja Trader
will it work on stocks yes it will work
on stocks will it work on
Forex no um problem with Forex
is the data is not centralized the way
it is generally from stock market and
how it is from um the CME Group you know
because it's one exchange they trade
everything you know the problem with
Forex is all the big Banks they they
have white labels okay what white label
is the they give their Forex front end
to a company and then that company
offers it out you know as as a broker's
business so yeah you could be
trading front end that's being provided
by deuts bank and somebody else could be
trading a front end that's provided by
Barclays and you're getting data from a
completely different source so the data
is not centralized in that sense and
it's not giving you accurate
representation of the market I mean in
generally it's it's mostly right but
it's um not really you people say what
about Bitcoin you U last year I really
started jumping big into Bitcoin but um
who really trades Bitcoin it's where you
just buy it you just holdal it right you
don't really buy and and sell maybe on a
short term you move from one crypto to
another but um on the CME
Bitcoin yeah you can you can use it um
ninja Trader does provide access
to allows you to connect your uh Ninja
Trader up to
coinbase and I think one or two other
exchanges but you honestly the data that
comes from there is not really good for
orderflow because it it doesn't really
show you the true bid and the offer
and the one nice thing about some of
these exchanges is at least you you're
getting the data from them and you can
trade that exchange whereas with Forex
you know you may be getting your data
from data company a but you're trading
you know through a front end through a
bank which has slightly different
data so anyway um if there's any other
questions I want to keep you guys on too
long I've gone about an hour and a half
um you know just send me a message Mike
at orderflows is my email but again get
started go to orderflows dcom off3 and
again you know the the links are in the
chat so that you may um download the
book or go directly to that page
orderflows docomo three so thanks
everybody thanks for taking this time
out and have a great rest of the day and
rest of the week bye-bye